as traumatized fans of Game of Thrones
know all too well lady Catelyn Stark was
shockingly and brutally slain in the
penultimate episode of season 3 but with
the show's final season about to arrive
fans are once again wondering could she
somehow still be alive on the surface it
sounds impossible after all the infamous
red wedding scene couldn't have been
more clear about the deaths of Catelyn
her new daughter-in-law to Lisa and her
son Robb Stark the erstwhile King in the
north
after being betrayed by Lord Roose
Bolton and Lord Walder Frey who had been
secretly conspiring with the villainous
House Lannister to destroy the Starks
Robb Tulisa and Catelyn were all stabbed
to death in horribly graphic fashion
there's no doubt about it
she was very definitely dead but is she
going to stay dead look who know so much
yeah well it just so happens that your
friend here is only mostly dead there's
a big difference between mostly dead and
all that first it's important to
remember that people come back from the
dead in Game of Thrones all the time
both Jon Snow and beric Dondarrion have
done it thanks to the kiss of life from
the fire-god known as the Lord of Light
and then on the slightly less happy side
of things the night king has been
resurrecting the dead for eons forming a
zombie army that includes not just
giants but a giant dragon
so it's theoretically possible that
Catelyn could be brought back but more
importantly it's actually already
happened in the books that is author
george RR martin who wrote the fantasy
novels that form the basis for Game of
Thrones resurrected Catelyn not long
after the red wedding with beric
Dondarrion surrendering his own
immortality in order to return Catelyn
to the land of the living as the
vengeful Lady Stoneheart for her part
actress Michelle Fairley told
Entertainment Weekly that Catelyn would
not be returning regardless of what
happened in the books
yeah the characters dead she's dead you
respect the writers decision I knew the
arc and that was it
they can't stick to the books 100% it's
impossible they only have 10 hours per
season they have got to keep it dramatic
and exciting and extraneous stuff along
the way gets lost in order to maintain
the quality of a brilliant show still
people associated with Game of Thrones
have been known to lie in the past in
order to prevent spoilers most famously
for example the folks at HBO swore up
and down for
year that Jon Snow was actually really
dead for good after being betrayed at
the end of season five naturally of
course he was back on his feet in season
six plus even some of the show stars
have publicly hinted that more major
characters will also be brought back
from the grave on the side of the night
king in 2017 Nikolaj coster-waldau who
plays Jamie Lannister told Esquire the
beer is that I would be turned into one
of those undead that would suck you know
some of the main characters are going to
get turned they are going to be some
blue-eyed main characters running around
and god I hope it's not me some fans
though think that Catelyn has already
reappeared as Lady Stoneheart in season
seven passing through the background of
a scene at Winterfell at the same moment
her daughter Arya mentioned her you
swore to serve both my mothers don't is
didn't you and others believe that the
first season eight trailer which shows
the stark children gathering in the
family crypt hints at catlins return
all because I couldn't love a motherless
but it still seems pretty unlikely that
Catelyn will ever return don't worry
though
Game of Thrones has plenty of big fish
to fry dangling plot threads to tie up
and mysteries to solve in its final six
episodes so even if cat never makes a
surprise return viewers will still have
plenty of juicy storylines to sink their
teeth into when season 8 premieres on
HBO on Sunday April 14 check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about Game of Thrones
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]